can a Catholic hold to the view that
these were the sons of James from a
previous marriage and therefore Jesus
Step Brothers or must they believe these
are Jesus's
cousins see are you
listening are you
listening you guys
listening why because I'm going to show
you how to destroy the misuse of Mark 63
to4
by anti-catholics anti-
Orthodox anti-catholics anti- Orthodox
but you got to listen in this
article John B lighfoot
shows with the possible exception of
tertullian and that's not certain Listen
to me he says if you read all the early
Christian writings prot evangelium James
lesser early churchmen whether
theologians apologists fathers they all
believe
Mary had no children that they didn't
disagree ttan he says maybe the possible
exception but he says it's not certain
now William has references showing
tertullian did not deny Mary's Perpetual
virginity you must read this because he
shows right here I quote I'm not going
to quote it now but it's there in
bold go and read in bold right here it's
long
long and I did a session on this already
all
right I'm gonna sum up what he
says the dominant
view the dominant view listen
Catholics the dominant View Early on
very
early and what was the majority view is
that these were the sons of Joseph from
a previous marriage you can find early
on The View these are his cousins but
the dominant View and early view was
these are Joseph's sons from a previous
marriage who then influen majority of
Christians to adopt the view these are
Jesus's
cousins not the sons of Joseph Jerome
Jerome later on adopted the view these
are his cousins and because Jerome is a
giant his
influence impacted majority of
Christians to believe these are Jesus's
cousins okay now if the earlier View and
the dominant view was these are the
children of Joseph from a previous
marriage why is it then later on they
went with the view of C
and why the debate why the
confusion okay my assumption is this the
reason
why there was a view out there that said
that these are Jesus's cousins not the
children of Joseph and the reason why I
believe Jerome picked it up and because
of his influence it became the dominant
view after Jerome notice after Jerome
4th Century the dominant view in the
westw these are G's cousins my
understanding is
this that there were some
who
believed that Joseph himself remained a
virgin you with me
there Joseph himself was a virgin so
when that became a
view held by influential Christians that
Joseph himself was a
virgin then it made sense they would go
with the view these are Jesus's cousins
listen but early on and the dominant
view was Joseph was already married had
children from a previous
wife and that's why they're called
Jesus's brothers because they were Step
Brothers now why is that beautiful that
means no matter what position you take
you destroy the Protestant objection let
me show you how to do it you ready now
with that all in view the documentation
is there and who documented it John be
Lightfoot did you know that John be
Lightfoot himself took the view that
these are not the actual Brothers of
Jesus
Christ did you know another renowned
reputable Protestant scholar who wrote a
book on the relatives of Jesus
and William has the book sent me a PDF
copy of it Richard bam a Protestant
wrote a book on Jesus's relatives and he
argues that the evidence is these are
not the children of Mary the biological
Brothers of Christ from Mary's womb and
he believes and holds to the view that
these were the cousins of
Jesus yes that's
why right there in the prot evangelium
our oldest extent Source teaches Joseph
was quite old and had children from a
previous marriage right
William okay are you with me there so if
we're going to use the Proto evangelium
as being our oldest extent
Source giving us accurate
Traditions accurate oral
Traditions then this Source teaches they
are brothers of Jesus
because they were the sons of Joseph
from previous
marriage now you ready see this is what
I pray the Holy Spirit helps
me I pray the Holy Spirit helps me not
only parent arguments but dig deeper
sharpen those arguments and make them
more airtight so I can help you make the
best possible defense so I started
thinking about this how can I make these
arguments stronger and how can I
anticipate objections and Destroy them
now let me help you you
ready you
ready okay let's go here they'll say see
Mark 33135 then Jesus's mother and
brothers arrived Standing Outside they
sent someone in to call him and a crowd
was sitting around them they told him
your mother and your brothers are
outside looking for you who are my
mother and my brothers he asked then he
looked at those seated in the circle
around them and said here are my mother
and my brothers whoever does God's will
is my brother and sister and mother so
then James White in a debate said so you
want us to believe that in actuality
they saying these are your mother and
cousins and the audience
laughed mother and cousins come on and
they laughed all right they'll use this
watch
here Mark 6: 3 to 4 isn't this the
carpenter isn't this Mary's son and the
brother of James Joseph Judas and Simon
aren't his sisters here with us and they
took offense at him now those who hold
that these are the relatives of Christ
will say the brothers here are
not literal biological Brothers they are
his cousins his
relatives and as William and others will
do they'll say you know how we know
because of verse four the parallel Jesus
said to them a prophet is not without
honor except in his own town among his
relatives
ginin in his own home so here the
argument is you see they are not his
brothers but his relatives raised in the
same home but because they were raised
in the same home because they were so
close they are called brothers and
sisters okay now I
anticipate the Protestant saying this
are you ready
I'm trying to anticipate their objection
you ready to hear this a Protestant can
say no yep speaking about Sun jenus
exactly same Greek word no it doesn't
mean they are his
cousins and that the reason why they're
called his brothers sisters because
they're raised in the same
home on the
contrary the reason why Jesus can speak
about his relative relatives is because
they were related to him how were they
related to him they were his brothers
and
sisters in other words they're saying
it's a
reverse we are told what kind of
relatives they
were they were his brothers and sisters
and if you're my brother you're relate
it to me so they'll flip and saying no
no no no you got it
wrong we are already told who are his
relatives what relatives uncles aunts
cousin no brothers and
sisters so it's not that they are
cousins raised in a some same home and
because they're so close they're called
brothers and sisters it's the
opposite we are being
told they are his relatives because
they're his brothers and sisters you get
the
argument so in other words it becomes
stalemate that's what a Protestant going
to say and you're going to object and
you get
nowhere no I disagree they're only
called brothers and sisters because
these were his cousins his relatives
raised in the same home and because of
that close connection Affinity they're
called brothers and sisters though they
were his cousins his relatives
Protestants no I disagree with you the
reason why Jesus says his relatives in
his home because we're told what kind of
relationship he had with them what kind
of relatives they were they weren't his
own uncles they weren't his aunts they
weren't his cousins they were his
brothers and sisters well stal me no one
wins and you can say I disagree and he
can say he
disagrees but let me show you if we go
with the
view that doesn't mean they
win that just means they won't get
obliterated clobbered it'll be a
stalemate meaning if you're a prod
you're going to say I disre the Catholic
you're Catholic you're going to say I
discreet the
Protestant but let me show you the way
to collab
them you ready if we go with the view
they are Joseph's children from a
previous marriage now you
win either position is good but I'm
saying when I'm now confronted with this
I know how to bury them John 145 Philip
found told him we have found the one
Moses wrote about in the law and whom
the prophets also wrote Jesus of
Nazareth the son of Joseph just like
they say Jesus's mother's mother
brothers and sisters they also say
Joseph is his father the son of Joseph
watch where I'm going with this because
I want to make it as sharp as possible
destroy objections leaving them no
stone right no stone that's unturned son
of Joseph all right John
64142 at this the Jews there began to
Grumble about him because he said am I
the bread that came down from heaven I'm
sorry I am the bread that came down from
heaven they said is this not the son of
Joseph whose father and mother we know
how can he now say I came down from
heaven so this is what I tell the
Protestants what's Joseph Jesus's
biological
father no
he was his legal father right yes and
therefore he was his legal son right yes
likewise just like Joseph is not his
biological
father his brothers are not his
biological Brothers they are his step
brothers because Joseph is
his adoptive father you get the
point they are no more literally his
biological Brothers than Joseph is
biological father even though he said to
be the son of Joseph and they're said to
be his brothers and
sisters you can still affirm they are
his brothers and sisters legally
adoptively just like Joseph is his
father legally and adoptively and you
still
win after this Jesus went around in
Galilee he did not want to go about in
Judea because the Jewish leaders there
were looking for a way to kill him when
the Jewish Festival of Tabernacles was
near Jesus's brother said to
him leave Galilee go up to Judea so the
disciples there may all see the works
you do no one wants to become a public
figure acts in secret since you are
doing these things show yourself to the
world for even his own brothers did not
believe in him what brothers the sons of
Joseph just like he's not the biological
son of Joseph
John
642 John 145 they are not the biological
brothers and sisters of Jesus they are
the legal brothers and sisters of Jesus
because they're the sons of Joseph and
Joseph is his legal
father bye bye Protestant objection it's
over which brings me to my final Point
here if they tell youwell how do you
know they are Jesus's legal brothers and
sisters the Bible doesn't say it I know
it from the same sources from which you
know Mark wrote Mark Matthew wrote
Matthew Luke wrote Luke and acts John
wrote John from the same sources who
preserved your Cannon the early
Christians that's how I know if these
early Christians can be trusted to
preserve your gospels and tell you who
wrote them they can be also trusted to
tell you who the brothers were game
over you
understand why I ask the spirit to help
me go deeper take arguments and try to
make them sharper to make you guys
unbeatable in the
battle why do you think I mentioned this
article here's your full documentation
they all
taught Mary Had No Children John be
leftwood admits it no one taught Mary
had
children they taught these were either
Jesus's brothers because they were
cousins which became the do dominant
View later but the earliest and majority
of you was these are Jesus's brothers
because they are the sons of Joseph of a
previous marriage so they they are his
legal Brothers his step brothers because
Joseph was his legal
father you see now we made the argument
sharper so if they tell me well hold on
it says his mother and brothers and his
brothers sisters are named I go yeah
they are his brothers and sisters what
do you mean they are his legal brothers
and sisters to step brothers and sisters
cuz they're the sons of Joseph from a
previous marriage
and just like Jesus can be the son of
Joseph not biologically legally they can
be his brothers and sisters legally not
biologically you got it you understand
whether you take the cousins view they
can't refute you at best it's stalemate
or if you take that they are the legal
brothers and sisters his step brothers
sisters because they're the Sons and
Daughters of Joseph riva's
marriage they can't refute that because
you if they ask you where you get that
from I got it from the same Christians
who told you mark wrote Mark Luke wrote
Luke and acts Matthew wrote Matthew John
wrote John who preserved those
scriptures the early Christians and none
of them believed Mary had any children
after Christ so if you can't trust them
in that regard how do you know
that they can be trusted to tell you
these are the gospels inspired by the
spirit through these men you can have
your cake and eat it too